It sort of pains me to say this, because we've
been saying for months we need to be primarily
led by doctors about the virus, not by politicians.
But Dr. Deborah Burk's has become a primary
disseminator of laughable Trumpian propaganda.
And Dr. Brooks is no longer a trustworthy
source of information in this entire thing.
It doesn't mean everything she says is wrong,
but she is no longer a trustworthy source
overall.
Dr. Deborah Brooks actually defended Donald
Trump's outrageous comment about bleach injections
as Trump talking out loud and having dialog
in real time as he synthesizes and assimilates
data that he has been presented.
Now, there is a really important tell here
in the video I'm about to play for you that
what Dr. Brooks is saying is B.S.
Let's look at the videos very short.
Twenty five seconds.
See if you can pick out the tell that Dr.
Brooks is being dishonest when he gets new
information.
He likes to talk that through out loud.
They really have that dialog.
And so that's what dialog he was happy having.
I think he just saw the information at the
time immediately before the press conference,
and he was still digesting that information.
So the tell there that shows us that Dr. Brooks
is being dishonest is that she had the idea
to say, oh, Trump had just seen this information
for the first time.
Meaning a minute before he made this crazy
bleach comment.
But the problem is that Donald Trump said
during the meeting, during the briefing, he
had already received this briefing about disinfectants
earlier in the day.
And as Dr. Burke's is saying or about to say,
Trump was reacting in real time as he learned
about this.
She realizes, wait a second, I can't say that
because that would contradict Trump.
Trump already said during the briefing, I
got this briefing earlier and I thought it
was so interesting.
I wanted it presented here.
So in real time, Dr. Burke's extends her sentence
and says, I think he just saw the information
at the time.
Pause immediately before the press conference.
Check out that pause as Dr. Brooks realizes.
Oh, wait a second.
I need to say more or this is going to be
obviously a lie.
And so that's what dialog he was happy having.
I think he just saw the information at the
time immediately before the press conference,
and he was still digesting that information.
So she is now a Trump brownnoser.
She's refusing to tell it like it is on premature
reopening.
She resisted saying that it was a concerning
decision that Florida made 10 days ago to
reopen beaches or whenever it was.
And remember that she also made this absolutely
insane claim a few weeks ago about how Donald
Trump just uses data to make decisions.
And all of the stuff that we simply know is
not it is not true.
And Trump has no attention span for how would
you describe the job President Trump is doing
behind the scenes and in front of the cameras
during these daily briefings that we're seeing?
What's your perspective, Dr. Burke's?
He's been so attentive to the scientific literature
and the details and the data.
And I think his his ability to analyze and
integrate data that comes out of his long
history and business is really been a real
benefit during these discussions about medical
issues, because in the end, data is data and
he understands the importance of the granularity.
And I think he's been really excited about
finding the level of detail that we've been
able to now bring.
Over the last few weeks to really understand
who is at the greatest risk for severe illness,
what Trump is analyzing data at a granular
level to understand the details of this pandemic.
That interview was back when Trump had more
recently said, we have 15 cases and we will
soon have zero.
This is the Trump that last week wondered
aloud about injecting bleach in isopropyl
alcohol to treat Corona virus.
Obviously, it's a lie.
Trump has been the opposite of what Dr. Deborah
Brooks claims.
So we've talked before about a doctor making
this calculation that if they disagree with
Trump too much, they get fired.
And if they get fired, they get replaced by
some total Trump sycophant and the country
is worth worse off.
Dr. Foushee made it clear, he said, listen,
I can't jump in front of the microphone every
single time Trump says something and correct
him.
It's just not feasible.
But as you've seen, Dr. Foushee has been sidelined
from the press briefings for a while now.
Dr. Bourke's has gone fully into not just
I won't contradict Trump when he lies.
She's starting to do this sort of sycophantic
stuff that reminds me of Donald Trump's crazy
letter from his doctor saying Trump would
be the healthiest president ever.
That's the type of disinformation that Dr.
Brooks is now a part of.
And it's terrible because we are at a desperate
deficit of actual a trustworthy medical professionals
that are administration adjacent.
Unfortunately, Dr. Brooks can no longer be
trusted.
And there are people writing to me saying,
you know, Brooks has Stockholm Syndrome.
She's starting to side with her Pachter captor.
I don't know about that.
The only thing that could be said is Dr. Brooks
believes that she can do more as a part of
the task force than not out than.
Out of it, and she believes that she has to
be saying these things about Trump as transparently
unbelievable as they are in order to remain
on the task force.
That's the most optimistic interpretation
of what Dr. Brooks has been saying.
But to go on Christian broadcasting and say
Trump synthesizes data in this great way and
other transparently untrue things, it seems
like it's overkill.
Let me know what you believe is going on with
Dr. Bourke's what explains her behavior.
And also, let me know what you think is going
on with Dr. Foushee, who's been missing from
the press briefings for more than a week now,
despite Donald Trump every once in a while
alluding to or even saying straight up.
Oh, yeah.
Well, you know, Tony Tony was part of the
meeting earlier.
What do you make of that?
I want to hear from you.
And we will have continued coverage of this
and other stories from today's program on
The David Pakman Show Instagram page.
If you are on Instagram, you can do much worse
from following at David Tacon show on Instagram